en el vídeo pasado nos quedamos muy pero
muy cerca de obtener la solución a la
ecuación diferencial que tenemos justo
acá arriba es decir a esta de aquí que
es nuestra ecuación diferencial
logística y estamos muy muy cerca de
encontrar esta solución porque solamente
nos falta un poco de álgebra para
obtener a n como función del tiempo y
para eso vamos a trabajar fíjate bien en
esta expresión que nos quedamos en la
vez pasada lo primero que se me ocurre
hacer es restar se uno de ambos lados
para quedarnos solamente con una
constante y para eso ante gemetro para
esto de aquí
y lo voy a volver a pegar justo por acá
porque ahora lo que quiero hacer es
restar se uno de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y que me va a quedar bueno si
resto se uno de este lado pues esto se
va ok vamos a quitar lo justo de aquí y
del otro lado me va a quedarse 2 - c1 c2
menos 1
ahora date cuenta que si yo resto a una
constante otra constante bueno pues esto
es lo mismo
que una única constante así que en lugar
de poner estas dos constantes lo único
que voy a poner es una única constante
la cual voy a llamar simple y
sencillamente se así que a esto le voy a
sumar una constante cm la cual resulta
de es de 2 - c 1 ahora date cuenta de lo
que tenemos aquí tenemos una diferencia
de logaritmos y como tenemos una
diferencia de logaritmos los podemos
reducir en un solo logaritmo es decir
que esto de aquí es exactamente lo mismo
que tomar el logaritmo natural y cuando
tengo el logaritmo natural de algo menos
el logaritmo natural de otro algo bueno
esto lo podemos reducir en una división
esto es exactamente lo mismo que el
logaritmo natural de éste que es
dispositivo n entre a esta otra
expresión 1 - n entre acá y vamos a
ponerlo con este color
1 - n entre acá ok esto ya está reducido
en un único logaritmo y por otra parte
igual a esta parte que tengo aquí así
que vamos a atraparla y la voy a poner
justo por aquí esto es igual a rt más
ahora qué te parece si pasamos este
logaritmo natural con su función
contraria del otro lado o dicho de otra
manera es decir que tomamos el lugar es
natural de esto de aquí es exactamente
lo mismo que pensando de la siguiente
manera podemos decir que la exponencial
elevada esta potencia nos va a dar
exactamente esto que tengo aquí o dicho
de otra manera vamos a aplicar la
función exponencial a ambos lados de
esta ecuación y entonces que me va a
quedar bueno del lado izquierdo
solamente me va a quedar esta parte de
aquí es decir el lugar es natural con
exponencial y se eliminan ok y solamente
me quedo con esta parte de aquí déjame
bajar un poco en la pantalla
un poco esta pantalla ok mientras que
por otra parte ante el otro lado me voy
a quedar con que esto es exactamente
igual que la función exponencial am
vamos a ponerlo así que he elevado a
esta potencia que tengo aquí así que
vamos a escribirlo ha elevado a la rte t
t con el color blanco ok
más c más ahora date cuenta de lo
siguiente he elevado a la rte
por las 62 exponentes es exactamente lo
mismo que tomar me he elevado a la rtm y
esto a su vez multiplicado por el
elevado a la potencia c ahora si yo
elevó a una constante bueno pues esto
también es una constante por lo tanto no
carguemos constantes demás y voy a
quitar todo esto y voy a poner solamente
una constante es decir que he elevado a
la rtm lo voy a multiplicar por una
constante lo cual es lo mismo que él
de lujo esto ya está mucho más fácil de
trabajar y además ya estamos muy cerca
de lo que queremos y ahora es hora de
resolver para n y para eso dejan bajar
un poco más esta pantalla ok y vamos a
trabajar con esto es más déjenme hacer
una pequeña línea por aquí para que
estemos separando con lo que está acá
arriba
ok vamos a empezar justo por aquí y
ahora lo que quiero que veas es justo lo
siguiente que si yo ahora tomo esta
parte de aquí y es más para no
confundirnos primero vamos a ponerle
nombre estas constantes esta vamos a
suponer que es muy constante 1 ok
esta fue mi constante 1 ok pero aquí
cuando yo elevé todo a la exponencial
obtengo una constante nueva este lo voy
a llamar una constante 2 porque ahora lo
que quiero hacer es tomarme el recíproco
de esto que tengo aquí es decir en lugar
de poner n entre 1 - entre acá voy a
tomarme el recíproco y eso es tomarme y
déjame ponerlo con este color
1 - n
/ cam ok ya esto a esto mismo lo voy a
dividir entre esta en el que tengo aquí
solamente estoy invirtiendo el
denominador en el numerador y viceversa
ok y esto lo voy a hacer exactamente
igual que el recíproco de esta parte de
aquí ahora ten cuidado porque si yo me
toma recíproco esta parte de aquí bueno
en primer lugar me quedarían 1 entre c
todos pero 1 en 13 2
bueno pues también es otra constante así
que para no confundirnos más a esta
constante 1 en 13 2 le voy a poner el
nombre de ese 3 voy a decir que ésta es
muy constante número 3 ok
una constante distinta a esta constante
2 3 es lo mismo que uno en 13 2 y bueno
si me tomo el recíproco de elevado a la
rte eso es exactamente lo mismo
y lo voy a poner así que en elevado a la
menos
recuerda que cuando está dividiendo aquí
va a pasar con un signo negativo
- r elevado a la t ok
y bueno si yo lo que hago es ahora
dividir esta diferencia entre n
bueno pues voy a llegar a lo siguiente
si yo me tomo 1 entre n eso es uno entre
n ok pero en esta parte se va a reducir
porque cuando yo me tomé - am n entre k
entre n eso es exactamente lo mismo en
entre k entre n que uno entre k
ok y esto va a ser exactamente igual que
esta otra parte que tenemos aquí así que
déjenme atraparla ok y vamos a copiar y
pegar la ok y bueno todo esto parece ser
un buen recordatorio de nuestras clases
de álgebra pero bueno ya estamos muy
cerca de este final y ahora si te fijas
bien qué te parece si pasamos este de
aquí del otro lado
y deje metro perdón ok lo voy a copiar y
lo voy a pasar del otro lado pero con
signo contrario
y que si en este caso estaba con signo
menos bueno va a pasar del otro lado
consignó más ok y éste se va a ir es más
déjame atraparlo y quitando una vez esté
aquí lo voy a quitar ok y ahora si
nosotros queremos a n como función del
tiempo hay que tomarnos el recíproco de
este ya estamos muy cerca de obtener por
fin nuestra solución n n que depende de
ti y bueno te está en blanco así que
vamos a continuar con ese mismo color
ok snet él va a ser exactamente igual
que y aquí hay que tomarnos el recíproco
el recíproco de éste es decir es
exactamente lo mismo y déjame ponerlo
con este color que 1 entre 1 entre todo
esto que tenemos aquí así que déjame
atraparlo ok lo voy a atrapar ok y lo
voy a pegar ya lo tenemos aquí lo voy a
pasar justo para acá abajo dividiendo
ahora es que ya sólo llegar a este
resultado es bastante interesante por sí
solo
ya tenemos despejada por fin sin embargo
aun creo que podemos utilizar un poco la
información que tenemos allá arriba para
poder obtener esta constante número 3 y
además quitar esta fracción de aquí del
denominador y para eso bueno si nosotros
recordamos que estamos suponiendo que n
de 0 es igual a en el subíndice 0 y es
más déjame escribirlo por aquí
si nosotros recordamos que n n de 0 y
déjame ponerlo así aquí voy a poner un
paréntesis y aquí voy a poner 0 cuando
te vale 0 nosotros habíamos dicho que
esto es exactamente igual que en ese
subíndice 0 ok entonces vamos a obtener
así el valor de c3 y para eso vamos a
sustituir el valor de t por 0 en esta
ecuación que ya obtuvimos en esta
solución que ya obtuvimos y entonces
quienes en el subíndice 0 bueno pues en
el sub índice 0 y recuerda que el tiempo
va en color blanco esto va a ser
exactamente igual
las cuentan cuando yo sustituyó el valor
de t por 0 esta parte de aquí se va a
ser 1 elevado a la menos r por 0 bueno
pues eso es 1 y nos va a quedar 1
déjame ponerlo con este color me va a
quedar 1 entre un 3 más ok
c3 ok más a uno entre acá más uno entre
acá ok pero nosotros habíamos dicho que
suponiendo que n de 0 es en el subíndice
0 entonces esto es exactamente igual que
en el subíndice 0 y ahora si toma un ser
recíproco de ambos lados me va a quedar
que c 3 de tres más uno entre camps más
uno entre cada ok
/ cam esto es exactamente igual que uno
/ n 0 ok y si ahora lo que queremos
hacer es despejar hace 3 bueno
déjame bajar un poco más esta pantalla
creo que este vídeo está muy muy
laborioso pero ya estamos muy cerca del
final porque si aquí despejamos hace 3
bueno pues voy a obtener ese 3 es
exactamente igual que en 1 / n 0 ok ya
este lo voy a pasar con signo contrario
me va a quedar menos uno entre acá y
ahora sí si sustituyó el valor de ese 3
en esta ecuación de aquí voy a encontrar
la función logística que es la solución
de ecuación diferencial logística y ya
estamos muy cerca así que déjame ponerlo
por aquí si yo tengo n dt n de ti y te
va con color blanco para seguir con esta
misma distribución de colores en
es exactamente igual que esto de aquí
bueno pues que me va a quedar si ahora
sustituyó hasta tres por esta expresión
de aquí y déjame a hacer esta línea un
poco más grande para ahora sí poner a lo
que queremos en este tema quién va a ser
bueno pues esto me va a quedar uno
déjame ponerlo con este mismo color uno
entre y si te das cuenta aquí tengo c3
que multiplica a esta parte de aquí pero
se 3 vale esto entonces voy a
sustituirlo por este valor de aquí así
que vamos a poner lo justo por acá
ok ya esto lo voy a poner entre
paréntesis ok vamos a ponerlo entre
paréntesis y esto a su vez multiplicar
elevado a la menos 7 y a esto le sumamos
1 entre acá así que antes de meter para
esta parte de aquí también y la voy a
poner justo por acá ok
tengo esta parte de aquí multiplicando
ok con cuidado ok y ahora si no te gusta
que tengamos todos estos divisores o
todas estas fracciones en nuestro
qué te parece si para tener una
respuesta un poco más elegante
multiplicamos todo ya por último por en
el subíndice cero porque voy a
multiplicar todo por n n sub índice 0 ya
esto por acá y esto me va a simplificar
todas estas fracciones ok esto de este
lado es más
déjame atraparlo ok
y lo voy a pegar justo por acá ok
también porque voy a multiplicar tanto
arriba como abajo por esto mismo de aquí
y que me va a quedar sin multiplico
tanto arriba como abajo por esto de aquí
bueno pues date cuenta que vamos a
llegar justo a lo siguiente si yo
multiplico esto en la parte de arriba
voy a obtener a justo esta expresión de
aquí en el subíndice cero porque déjeme
poner que estamos en esta planta de
kleen esto va a ser exactamente igual y
en la parte de abajo que voy a obtener
bueno pues si te das cuenta en la parte
de abajo me va a quedar uno entre
en el subíndice 0 si a esto lo
multiplicamos por en el subíndice 0 por
camps
bueno pues date cuenta que solamente me
quedo con acá ok y después a esto le voy
a quitar y ahora si multiplicamos 1
entre acá por en el subíndice 0 por acá
bueno pues date cuenta que solamente nos
quedamos con en el subíndice 0 ok y esto
a su vez está multiplicando esto a su
vez está multiplicando ha elevado a la
menos rte
elevado a la menos r tm ok voy a poner
así elevado a la menos
r ok por el tiempo ok y ahora fíjate
bien en este último sumando si yo
multiplico 1 entre camps por en el
subíndice 0 por camps bueno date cuenta
que de aquí solamente obtengo en ese
subíndice 0 y de aquí voy a obtener
solamente n en su índice 0 y ya está
esto se ve mucho más elegante que tener
todas estas fracciones de aquí entonces
ahora sí si yo lo que quiero ver es
como una función del tiempo que crees
que obtuvimos por fin nuestra función
logística nuestra solución de nuestra
ecuación diferencial logística es esta
de aquí a esta de aquí le vamos a llamar
la función logística y ahora no pierdas
oportunidad de jugar con ella es más si
tú tienes internet te puedo recomendar
que intentes buscar la gráfica de esta
función logística por ejemplo puedes
utilizar el programa wolfram alpha o
también puedes intentarlo en cualquier
programa gráfica door o en tu
calculadora gráfica dora y te vas a dar
cuenta que esta que es nuestra función
logística es bien bonita porque va a
cumplirse justo lo que nosotros
queríamos esta va a tener las
propiedades que queríamos que tuviera va
a empezar en n 0 y va a empezar a crecer
y su tasa de cambio también va a ser
creciente y esta tasa de cambio va a
empezar a disminuir cuando nos
acerquemos a la población máxima
y aunque en los siguientes vídeos vamos
a trabajar con esta función logística ya
puedes empezar a jugar con ella podrías
preguntarte en cuánta población va a
haber después de un tiempo no sé lo que
se te ocurra en fin hasta el siguiente
vídeo